yeah
shall we hear that song I love you I
love you I love you Lisa happy birthday
to you bunch of I find the way I would
say
so
I
[Music]
hey here he is
Michel barbell I do
what's up
[Music]
hi doing man hey we were together
premiere right I think so yeah we were
by the spider-man your dress Doughboy
I was I was representing you both colors
for like a soldier what will by yourself
right I won by myself no I got I got I
got wins though you start with her she's
the only on trush I need a full board
cast Johnny rookie until you say to her
Oh Englewood High School Laker Jersey
now that's my high school what were you
though gladiators rounded me Vikings oh
wow the Vikings the Vice yeah so Y
accesses the restaurant and not that way
weight class 2000 2001 to 2005 all four
years wow man you graduated to first
grade of elementary man good times
[Laughter]
yeah what bull
legit Jerry Barone is formed out that's
it
alright man before that's it before you
catch our people man
if you're in anybody near with three
hours of me Raleigh North Carolina if
you want to come to my show I woke you
up with passes okay
Raleigh North Carolina through February
22nd through the 24th at the brand-new
improv and I meet his brand-new
and hit me up at fans at Philebus
world.com and that's for them and also
my limite right now don't be asking for
me no other [ __ ] ticket
don't be asking me for no san jose
nobile nothing else if it aint Raleigh
don't ask
by having Florida March 8 to 20 at the
brand new improv what's up fool these
are thinking of blowing and smoking a
fat cigar having some coffee
walking Texas March 25th at the San
Angelo Performing Arts Center Wichita
Kansas fun last time remember March 16
what you talk Kansas March 16 at the
Orpheum Theatre grand Sims where
Junction Colorado March 23rd Avalon
theater Dallas Texas March 29th through
31st
our little improv can't wait for
spiraled ever so busy model man yeah
Congrats bro give me a plate ribbon you
go check out for the big world on cars
last two overall upcoming shows man
guess where I was stuck meet you tell me
Wow for me bro doing a comedy show you
may encounter right
what's up you're Mexican right I am
Mexican too so I think yeah yeah his
parents were okay
yeah it's they're in so I wasn't nervous
I went to Birmingham
bro I don't know what to expect the
second time I went there the first time
brother was like nobody was there it was
the ring though it was 2015 during the
elections yeah crazy times they have
barely started charity build the wall
like it was the beginning of the build
the wall
like they have any receptive the wall he
says gonna build the wall but they were
you know but people were yelling all
Trump cuz of that white man got drunk
and you're not robbed there my said but
he left quite a bit gently into the 630
Dan
Wow 630 man it would say people walking
out of that place drug and eat drink and
they call it a night buy a pen yeah it
was a crazy evening man so I was a
comedy club and they the gentleman first
of all I'm gonna hear talking without
introduce you give it up for Mitchell do
bar oh you're actor what's up guys I met
them I met him briefly at the premiere
of the spider-man movie which oh yeah
right here yeah all has to be man that
movie gave hope for a lotta for
everybody who's not white you know cuz
cuz you know what you could just the
black spider-man you know a student
spider-man yeah [ __ ] up
spider-man in the outer world
yeah yeah right yeah I love that man it
was bad my favorite one even though that
show too much was a little Asian robot
one and oh yeah yeah yeah any Parker yo
Nicolas Cage character some point yeah
there's a text where he's like this man
when it rains the wind comes and the
wind smells like I don't know just with
the voices I moved around to I looked
down like his little cape or whatever
I'm done acting gonna I love you just
play Mexican right you get to play it
Israel Israelis everything right ah not
yet but I accidently put Rican right now
Porto Rican I don't know man i I don't
wanna I don't wanna die
yeah I lives you can
I don't wanna I don't wanna do a Dory
bro he sort of take out two voices
something that I really wanted nails
like the Columbia like you wish but zero
you know like oh I love that
wah ba-bah to our leader
he told me that I'm working the waters
has done away with Thomas so what was
that do pedals you note any apparent
well no propeller continum Oracle
apparel what about that hello what's up
fools oh man what happened bro bro about
twenty nine casino dogs you want you to
get the food they even give it to you oh
man I got there dude and they told me
someone from the casino showed up to get
it the dude lied to my face I was like
are you sure no one showed me like we
were a bunch of food everything we said
best a little Gator right gets there man
they tell a man so when I Riku - got it
- get it - yeah yeah yeah they told me
that like I know nothing knowing we sent
nobody I was the guy to come get
everybody was we're all drooling chuckle
sugar by yeah man but it's like an hour
away
Oh back it up in 30 minutes oh but you
need you need not think I name it what
security guard yeah well I was like who
who sent that here's like somebody from
the casino and like he didn't give me
any information food away I bet you
someone took it home oh there's my baby
by now it's some type of x-files episode
you know
is the food no judo called the guy said
no but we're gonna close already if they
open for us but the guys say all right
if I didn't want to stay open or well
they were leaning and stuff when we got
there like there is still like doing
busy work to finish up the night yeah I
don't know I fix sprinklers oh my god
what's up fool what's up bro what you
been up to you ready oh sure oh yeah I
got it I can't really say for who Wow
good man Congrats
so there was no video yeah yeah I'm
writing on show that's cool I'm excited
about it and yeah well I gotta like cut
myself out the budget but like it's cool
that I get like to do it on a high end
high end like platform for free talk
I've been doing thing of cell phones off
of video cameras if you do believe in
the project it doesn't matter if you get
paid at first as long as you transition
bro oh man you got the job where the
whiskers II really wow man you're the
north nice actually
Cortinas nice man nowhere tell I'm from
Mexico City born and raised
oh my life oh good yeah no smuggler of
toys yes yeah I didn't know the cultural
difference between like Mexico City
people
yeah it was like I blew my mind yeah man
I feel like Mexico cities a city that
has like a bad rep but once you're there
you're like ah this is [ __ ] man it's
a bigger city but still man like it's so
big that you have like the bad places
and you have the really good places also
man and I love it man it has so much
story like me when I was like he's right
about the bath
the bad part because what stuck my head
in that video one time on a Current
Affair yes a man is walking and I 10,000
look is robbed woman is that in Mexico
City though you don't happen in high tea
and they'll be like it was in California
yeah the runs Brazil I've never heard it
here like that happening in Mexico City
man like a man walking boy like ten kids
walking with little knives they strip
them down but again while they were
fastened to the next person
the I don't think it's Mexico but still
man you know like you can find places
like that but I do feel like you can
find places anywhere in the world man if
you go to the wrong place of town
dressing really well you know like you
get yourself in trouble what up dog the
sixteenth okay I used to know a guy
named his last name of RDC dog like I
saw Billy one time on a Current Affair
he set up a fake news but you know it
could have been it was like a bunch of
little kids they attack some business
guy and he [ __ ] took a [ __ ] what year
was that in the 90s for the 80s 83 well
I wasn't even born there in Lamba but I
don't think I don't think that that
would have
not anymore not anymore true man you
know and and it's like even like weird
to say but I feel like even though in
Mexico like everything that happens like
there's some type of like code yeah they
won't mess with kids they won't mess
with women like if you get it you
deserved it in a way you're getting
mixed up in there I mean you're usually
usually doing something wrong or going
down the wrong alley way very rare
bystanders are very rare it is man but
it's crazy you know like it's crazy all
over the world cuz here in here you can
go to a church and just get shot you
know so like it's a morality code
different in every country but uh but I
was telling like I feel like Mexico City
has a bad rap but once you get to the
city you're like nah this is this is
good it's a different world it's a
different world man it's a cultural
clash but it's so amazing that people
yeah it was crazy
I went in ninety-eight one time there's
a Washington yeah it's a straitjacket
they're like purse like cut off real
quick the camera cut off real quick and
then people are gone you can also seen
that should happen where you watch a
couple people try to rob somebody and
then like I seen it with my own eyes
yeah but that going back to the video
this will said he's seen and I've seen
horrible fools
and then they beat them up and then
[ __ ] hell talking about ten kids with
small knives all style and if you go to
tippy tippy toe oh yeah and you go there
you can get jacked as soon as the
[ __ ] when you can get a mammoth I get
my ivory and [ __ ] but I feel like that I
would want to do that there video shoot
in Tijuana oh yeah yeah the border I was
fearing for my life
[Laughter]
but what do you think is gonna happen I
felt good there you're white
Asian people take it forward by the wall
truth attraction of the okay man nobody
nobody wants to rise we went you'd like
that yet the American side like yes not
the board about the wall by the beach
yeah yeah French mark yeah we're you can
like touch finger yeah
used to be able to open they do they do
every weekend few hours in a weekend no
it's like every year something like that
[Music]
it was all like a be careful go over
there and a bunch of nodes you have
people at the beach you know like it's
gonna be Minutemen we're not reporting
everything yeah like if you ride your
bicycle there's a white doing a banger
he'll call a cop for for no reading
we're just driving double your permits
and everything is to color cops Fox Fox
News was there hello man no they got his
voice when he saw her bad Fox News was
there but but it went to the other side
of Mexico man with a party people are
nice people are they broken washed up
for that bar where they breaking down as
a [ __ ]
you guys did a revolution another right
next to the to the Bulls yeah right the
security looked at a the neighborhood
luckily he just got better cops showed
up only later on he was then I lock your
doors
[Music]
a memory stick we split the camera it
was him he wakes up east taco that go to
sleep bro any middle a heart a heart
stomach making his faith will read bro
like James Brown at the ribs are done
like crispy whatever Birmingham Broadway
with all nice in the south
how y'all doing welcome Lord nice cool
there's some good at ribs good [ __ ]
food man at Gabrielle's or is it didn't
I heard him what up what up what up i
sad that can you hit me fool but
Birmingham's a [ __ ] warrior squad get a
new stereo system but that Club fooled
the stardome dog it's a legendary stand
up look at that says Mexico City the
capital of kidnapping men on fire guys
tell me some movie yeah let's be as we a
little ball marcher and it is remake
imagine I don't think they can top it
man that cotton know that under man and
a fire with a remake of another movie
that came out in the 70s no way
throughout time places change cities
changed and of course the crime was
worse back then I mean then people were
getting kidnapped and you know like
weird a seven view it was more like he
was she was taken by Libyans whatever
city whatever it coach whatever year it
is to figure out what nationality that's
gonna be the bad person movies yeah yeah
yeah the bad before that it was like the
Germans
good and then it will be enough chill
bro it in a rebel yeah like the ocean I
really but we want Vietnam bro
watch the way rabble sorry Chuck Norris
good boy make sure like all those movies
was getting our generation happy to buy
guns later on oh they were setting they
were setting the dummy that's why so
many people in my age are generation
your generation [ __ ] 12 I've always
loved guns I think every gun you guys
don't have a good story I got like spot
a desert eagle that's all you have no no
they are yeah they are but they're not
you know they are no but or not if you
if you do want the cops don't come if
you if you want to get it you're gonna
get it matter I show there's a video
little guy go see I'm a law-abiding
citizen in the last century my girl I'm
not ruining my girls but how about the
Crips how about the Bloods are they're
gonna turn into girls why I gotta keep
mine something that you know protest the
military and the police are armed why
shouldn't we be armed but then I my
question was always like oh no how do
you know when it's
I'm that everybody's gonna rise up and
pick up their guns and fight back
against it's just gonna be you it's
gonna be overpowering us with their
weapons we should have be able to defend
ourselves against from experience the
LAPD has a lot of fences and they'll
just gate don't [ __ ] put a fence
around all these bad area and keep
everybody the National Guard okay yeah
I've seen that LPD but they have a lot
of gates
thank you quarantine areas quickly
realizes how hard it is to get away from
the police - huh / - am i up in the sky
like thirty five miles up in here you
look down and it's all it's a little
puzzle there's no way to run you God
thank you can't you can't outdrive a
helicopter that's the thing like what
that's like street racing got really
dangerous you you under a roof a tunnel
yeah yeah I think I always sound so easy
right it's like what you know is how you
can get away - you're like mom [ __ ]
get away in tunnels all the time but you
have to [ __ ] know what the [ __ ] is up
I think so you robbed the store after
you got into a fight with your lady you
probably get car punch everybody get
away man you know I was there in New
York I saw the plane going from my
office building and everything Wow I saw
the second plane go in the first one we
couldn't see cuz we only saw the back
Tower
but anyway the right after it happened
we couldn't call on her cell phones cell
phones didn't work there were lines
around the corner for landlines and we
had the only landline in our apartment
building too and people were running in
from the stock exchange using our
landline because cell phones wouldn't
work weren't working and people were
saying well it was because afterward
people are saying well it was because
the the tower there was a communication
tower on top of okay but yeah but it
hadn't fallen yet when we weren't able
to use the cell phones nothing had
service
nobody could call and also the National
Guard came in there like had martial law
down there yeah ain't no revolution it
was quick Oh the government strained it
like you it's like trying to play
basketball against a pro NBA player
everything you know everything was in
there and they're waiting for the moment
no that's the thing everything was
planned I hear bro even the Constitution
bro like they were like oh uh everything
and they're still doing it would think
things look yeah
Tex that's why no one wants to change
the constitution because it changes the
power levels that people have and that's
like oh no that's why I like for the V
one means like for men that's the new
thing fighting the Constitution through
loopholes found through arguing that
[ __ ] out well then what if they wait a
minute man but I thought this day was
posed to one of the way we want to
mm-hmm
what's up man I think about everything
man no I'm really happy man I'm really
happy to be with you guys I'm really
never your show man thank you a retrack
movie yeah I had the sperm into the
spider-verse
yeah for some reason I thought we see
them with that that one that one
premiere fool which one I see what was
up but this says
the denna thieves the den of thieves no
were you at that other one to the Amy
Schumer one no damn I wasn't you then
one of the premier about myself and I
saw a fan right there right he would
just chill in there by himself what a
date and if he was gonna go he'll get
walking around man and I said whoa what
are you doing right now man training you
want to go to the premiere right here
brother [ __ ] movie right yeah this
boy [ __ ] was happy bro
I give Wendy were at 30 she gave me the
passage for the after-party yes I said
here bro take come on going and then I
left hand they both have a poster up
everything the best night of my life do
the after party right and then that girl
she was with also two men just happen in
Hollywood tonight was Beverly Hills you
know I guess the good Instagram moments
yeah we're gonna use that to pay his way
and everything were used to tickets and
for him he's gonna talk about that night
for a while dude [ __ ] lying [ __ ]
embellish a little kid he was kicking it
with a rock that night I seen when you
were give him a [ __ ] because I was like
happy dog I mean that's like some VIP
[ __ ] right there for real no we can get
that [ __ ] well just get some scope so
how do you start acting broke through
family or something you inherited a
hundred percent man you know my mom
she's a really big comedian in Mexico
City was well oh yeah yeah she did
familia pollution and I repeat all that
stuff so since I was a little kid I was
always like interested I feel like it
was in my blood and I grew around the
set you know like she couldn't leave us
at her home so she would bring us on
and I would be like this little just
monkey going around what is this what is
that what does it work for you can I can
I just went into the into here and I can
see like you have two black magics the
millimeter of the lenses I know it's so
much
Oh in came a day where I was like okay I
want to do this for a living so I did
some work in Mexico City I saved up some
money and I told my mom I'm moving to LA
she's like what are you talking about I
was like I'm moving to LA I got my money
I'll see how it goes so I came here to
LA when I was 18 I was here too for two
years and a half then I had to go back
because I didn't have the right
paperwork to like work still the
security number and the socials and all
that snow doing it legal I was doing oh
yeah their visa I wasn't on the student
visa you know so I would I would
audition for stuff and they'll be like
okay you got it
give me your social I'm like Oscar and
visa they're like no your social yeah
and so then I went back to Mexico City I
got a part in a Telemundo show called
Senor acero it did really really well we
went there for five seasons yeah each
season seventy five episodes man so I
filmed over 200 episodes of that stuff
yeah it was amazing man hurry the other
day yeah it was a cheap man in Mexico
yeah you know I'm really happy do in
America that you pay less no no not
exactly
not if you surround your people yourself
with our people that know it so when I
went with Telemundo I'm proud to say
that the moon is like one of the only
Hispanic RTVE you know production and
business thing is to do really well
content you know they got bought by
NBCUniversal Comcast so now they have a
standard you know they have you upgrade
their cameras their lenses their schools
like 380 B and I think up or their
payment cars bro how about you pay you
read the next few months stay here and
it's crazy cuz also like they'll give
you this contract and it's called the
exclusive contract line or you can only
work with that company whoa and it's
like okay Felipe
you're gonna work with me we're gonna do
a show for six months and the other six
months you're not gonna do anything but
I'm still gonna pay you 20% of what I
did pay you so you know like some people
desperate to like okay go it's legal man
I even did it with Telemundo but it was
more of projects you know like it was
more human they're like you're here with
us for this project we're gonna talk
about the money every project that comes
with oh and so I finished with Telemundo
and I got my big break on this new show
called deadly class yeah call me boy
yeah man sighs yeah executive produced
by the Russo brothers the directors of
infinity war and endgame this comes out
this year it did already matter
yeah I actually like we did the
mid-season finale my character he's a
bad guy so he just got killed and the
response for four people was amazing man
like I wanted now we have a lot of
people like watching this stuff you can
watch it right now on Sci Fi every
Wednesdays at 10:00 and most on items
the episodes go if you buy the season
pass but after after sci-fi I think
we're gonna go on a streaming service so
I'm hoping Netflix Hulu Amazon I got so
much better - they did did yeah they did
man like we had a meeting and they're
like yo whoa sci-fi is rebranding
themselves and we got too big too big
shows that are gonna help us rebrand
that'd be class and night flyers that
week last night flyers and so night
fliers came out that really well now
deadly class is out and it's doing
amazing man amazing and so I'm really
proud to be a part of the show and be my
first villain the first bad guy
representing Latinos hell yeah yeah that
feel to be a bad guy if it's really well
man cuz you know I really try to do a
different bag I know like a
one-dimensional villain so it's like a
bad guy that likes to do bad things
right my character is more into like a
sociopath type of the master thinker
what's up he's a dog walker today I am
what no no I do have like dog walking
like eight dogs so like I can be
considered
shelter yo yeah yeah kind of we're gonna
do that in Mexico there's a lot of stray
dogs sang by MBC so you could wash your
whole Lupe people yeah I hope so
yeah oh yeah no that's Fox Fox well it's
actually you say it's is us a network is
a network but it's yeah it's us a
network but it's with our Fox also and
yes I was there I did us a guest
appearance that was supposed to be two
episodes and turned out to be 12 oh man
yeah it was like yeah you're gonna
you're gonna come here for uh you're
gonna come here for two episodes and
then I was like okay I'm done and then I
got another episode I was like and it
said Kiki Jimenez which is my character
and I read and he was there then I got
another and another
so I did the second season I did the
third season as well but then the times
kind of clashed with Telemundo and
Sailor Moon has first option so I I had
to be killed off in queen of the south
as well and and then I had to be killed
off in Senora Sarah to be in sci-fi to
be killed off to be here some people to
pretend to rob you it was crazy because
the three dance Marlene right here the
three deaths that I did were different
you know the first one I'm queen of the
south I just got the episode and I saw
that I died and I didn't know I was like
oh my god and the episode ended with
Kiki screams so I was like did I die
hey buttburn he got nailed into a wall
so you were acting like you were gonna
live will you see in a row I'm like okay
brother yeah oh if I was if I don't
sleep I look at look at the script yeah
my character in the front page okay and
I see my curve to the last page and I
say yes
we done [ __ ] see my character's name
I took to the last page I said I see him
the last page I say yes to the rope yeah
man and so I did that then the the
second the second death in signora cero
I had to negotiate it you know because I
was going to Vancouver for a deadly
class and so I had to be like guys I'm
going on Coover we got a kill off the
character they're like what do you mean
we're like yeah man sorry but we we got
to work it out
and so I will expire weekend and so that
death I kind of have control over and
then the third death on deadly class it
was written in the comics man you know
like I read that the first volume of the
comic and I saw it and I was like okay
this is happening
well sooner or later main character's
name is Chico Chico just check on the
powers he doesn't have any powers man
the story follows like a street kid
that's wanted for mass murder but he
didn't commit it and so he gets abducted
in an academy of assassins I was like
the new generations of the most that
biggest criminal organizations send like
the young to like train and become the
next new assassins and take over the
busy scatter these kind of storylines
what's really [ __ ] up my life they
would apply my life told me I was better
off and I went to my aunt's house and I
thought that somebody's gonna take me in
like will like first Prince of bel-air
bro family I Felipe Padilla rough comes
Tino somewhere over here or or they or
somebody they stop me whip the guys
about whipping they get about I thought
maybe somebody take me you know what
here's a whip I'm gonna cruise you could
be later than Jones
we hope it I'm over gonna doesn't have
AIDS the cops are chasing they can't
find you they make it run you back Wow
no buts about running the cops to a
Heisman Trophy how here boy I gotta say
man this is this comic was different
because it's really graphic it's really
dark it's based on the 80s so you know
like these guys do drugs all the time
they're getting trips they murder people
so I like that man you're like I read
the comics and I was like this is it man
this is this is this is my big break I
knew that death was coming so I knew I
had limited time I was like this is my
stepping-stone that's cool cuz it
doesn't characterize you as that
character to like you can play other
roles from it a hundred percent man
[Laughter]
[ __ ] cisco over here you're training
it said on your little bio that you were
trained at a Televisa's Institute Mexico
City did use in a lot of places okay not
just that's why that was when I was a
kid you know like you have it's crazy
because like
Televisa has their own academy so you go
there and you act in the Luisa so that
just sounds bananas to me but uh but I
was really really young I was like five
and they had like the kids program so I
went there when I was a kid I still on
the rest of me I don't know why but then
I went to Miami I went to the New York
conservatory of Dramatic Arts I want to
tell our other Academy to Iowa Arts
Academy in California so like I've been
around man like I've taken the best of
many worlds and tried to like mix that
because because you know like the thing
is like if you act that that long in
Mexico City it's like you get infected
by that telenovela type of performance
yeah everything's big or everything goes
everything goes higher and everything
that I say instead of just bringing it
down you know my favorite part novella
boy when you're driving crying yeah boys
okay and you gotta love them to get what
I love also it's like the music man like
they don't even care like I want a piano
and it's Dean
you know like in England yesterday yeah
[Music]
this mother adopts the girl in in a
wheelchair
and so as you can pick her up and then
and then she comes she comes into the
room yeah she comes into the room and
she sees like I don't know like her song
like kissing there the girl in the
wheelchair and she goes bananas and yo
and she gets killed like five times in
the same scene but [ __ ] does not die I
actually get stabbed and then we start
walking she falls through the window
gets up it's like wow not a lot man
company - no no no no no lovely custom
in Europe of course yeah better but that
was a movie though right
yeah of course a Lumiere we watch you
know show the 80s and we're watching
General Hospital and the 26 million
people saw the wedding of that that
couple look we're talking about your
luck you'll get 8.6 now for that oh
you're lucky
what is it Oh Mitchell yo that's that's
Mexico City the whole the whole
population of Mexico City just watching
wedding and it's great because I feel
like the streaming services are taking
over to be man like TVs got a little
yeah I'm so many high tuition I think
there's gonna be a time we're like TVs
that you're gonna do one episode in nor
like a certain type of projects and then
the streaming services are gonna do way
more serious stuff or something like
that you're like the news for TV TV
shows for streaming sir you know like
their game with like so much more like
edgy air stuff that like showing being
more cursive they're being more
aggressive on like they're be more human
man you know like they're being more
human and people relate to that you know
like in Mexico City were we're blinded
by this quality of telenovelas we're you
know like even this cameras are better
than what we have in our studios in
Mexico and so when the streaming service
has come people the audience in Mexico
they still don't know what it is but
they're like their eyes are opening in a
way where they're like why is this shown
that flicks better than this telenovela
why it's like the story it's the
lighting it's the colors yes it's a
quality that's a little quality at all
in this day doing even the show that
they bring in from another country like
I saw the show called Gomorrah but it's
all colorful it's bright mm-hmm you
could you the whole city man like okay
I'm gonna do this polka matter is way
back I still don't know man I don't know
I think it's probably shot in Bolivia or
somewhere in Spanish but everybody other
Latinos they're dressed like you know I
get powder wigs bro yeah and they have
sleeves wow it's like a colonial time
country that said in Bolivia they're
like old Spaniards bro oh but they have
white powder wigs and they have a couple
of like black subjects who have part of
wigs too but they're anything is a
garden if you do it with such bad
quality it even seems disrespectful you
know really yeah just like a oh it's
good quality yes cuz I cuz like you say
white powdered wigs like oh the wigs
Benjamin yeah those guys yeah very
classy you know George Washington type
of stuff yeah man but I'm really happy
to see that the quality for us actors
and the diversity on the casts are
getting better
oh and now they get the Mexican and
they're gonna go for a Mexican late
like a like in the past it was just like
oh it's a Mexican let's just bring the
UN Puerto Rican the Puerto Rican let's
start him up and let's give him a gun
he's Mexican it's like nah man what know
if my netflix has shown more Mexicans on
like last season you're that then all
the network just announced that they're
opening their new offices in Mexico City
you know like they they saw that the
Mexican market is a great market to bet
and they're like okay we're gonna do a
streaming service just for Mexico you
know so now the whole company's because
TV in Mexico is like like a monopoly man
you know there's three companies
Televisa david Televisa TV Azteca
and well that was one that Carlos Aseema
wanted to open but Televisa interesting
I got together and didn't let him so I
feel like this guy's north Telemundo's
underhood let me sell em know Telemundo
those are my guys telly this is way
different for gonna be on their own
una vez Yuans you only Calais and
Televisa are the same okay
telemundo is their own thing and they
air actually in the US but telemundo
also has a branch called Telamon
international which brands in which airs
in mexico in argentina and all that
stuff but telemundo is the one that's
really stepping their game up but now
they're they're in a hard spot because
you know like they they they did it so
big when they did the narco series you
know when you're de los cielos all that
type of stuff but i really do believe
that it's good for a while like they got
a move out of the narco series man cuz
yeah it's gonna like like like like you
said like bro like we will get 1.5
million in rating and that would be like
oh what a good day and right now 500 500
k it's a good day you know so people are
going away man and we should just redo
white movies boil a little bastards up
BG Santa oh yeah we're at the mall with
hickeys on it bro yeah I have to take
the bus every day bro talk once the bus
die man cannon from East LA oh so much
you go what can people find you wet
Rodriguez Jr
yeah man episode 53 is up please check
that read and yeah what else Facebook is
right Charlie what's up
oh you find me on youtube at R ok Johnny
and I do a podcast on Nick and Johnny
[Laughter]
let me get a hold of you mean I just go
to my Instagram mich underscore duv al
mich underscored Oh Val and then that
websites is gonna take you all over
check me out dishes I have an audition
right after this man what's him like 3
p.m. so I'm good early prepare yourself
you do all over the lines of course man
you know I was are in our group I know
how you psych out the other actors bro I
know some bad the one if a hello to
interrupt you a respectful about that
like if I'm if I'm really there like
they'll know cuz cuz I wear this is a
good technique guys if you don't want
anyone headphones even if I'm not
listening to music I just put them on
and people don't get close to me bono me
sell defund and so I put on my
headphones I don't listen to music
sometimes I do but like what I do is I
do something called the script breakdown
like I try to find a character because
you know like the lines are not that
they're I of course are important don't
take me wrong
but they're not that substantial in an
audition as long as you have a character
you look at the her you look at the
lines oh did you focus on her [ __ ] up
bloody to my advice no no yeah you
always gotta like a newspaper like you
always gotta be off-book man like I
always have my sites because you never
know like you're blanked out sometimes
because I go into the romanov yeah man
I'm lighting yellow in black he's from
Mexico City are
like you can do and it's really good
it's like I was like right here in
actual joy mexican natural is known for
his roles in Telemundo Senora Sara and
effect you know like I can look but then
my delivery is always to you if you're
talking to me I can look really really
quick like something I'm like this so
mission of all right ha like I would say
go off-book men learn the lines my heart
just have it there they tell me
determine free but don't ever go off
book you get off book means you don't
need to rely on your script this guy can
I take the richness is gonna get so like
you can do that too
yeah no no you know like there's so many
actors like I was I was looking up
audition for like Game of Thrones
I was looking actually for auditions for
like you know like Al Pacino or Leonardo
DiCaprio like that top those additions
and bro you can see them look at the
paper and and just look at look at the
person be there be there look at the
paper again look at the person but they
have such a character that the lines are
not even important because he has a
character down the character I would say
go off-book you don't learn the line oh
they really like me have them there if
you ever forget but just go what I do is
if there's a camera I make my own
character and I look at the other side
that I know it's better for me but if
there's no camera you look at the person
that's reading to you and you make one
of the little like look like the one is
the guy that is reading the reader the
reader that's giving you replica you
look at that guy or that girl and you
and you make them be in the scene and
it's amazing you know like I've had
scenes where it's like really emotion
I'm like why are you doing this why and
you see them just like
I don't know why I don't like oh yeah
I'm making you feel something you know
so I'm good slightly loud out loud
afterwards if you're going for like a
drama and then you just go goodbye to
Corey Holcomb okay would it do he said
he goes in there and you start talking
to the people that are dead dogs can't
hurt you so much I'm making her laugh
they didn't even audition cuz he doesn't
even remember I said that's a talent hey
guys what's up my name is Mitch so tell
me what were you guys from there like ah
we're running late can we do the
audition and I'm like okay you gotta get
to work bro no [ __ ] monitor make sure
you mention it because people who are
listening ug z magazine this fool
started at Stella Adler Academy he's
breaking it down like when you see them
I was breaking it down like me like you
do like you break down the whole script
oh just your audition yeah for the
audition
ah I'm script no no like sometimes
you'll get the script and sometimes you
just get the audition in your script an
hour before the audition as you pitted
me I've always say you know what [ __ ]
daddy yeah it's all it's hard man
because you know I ready though ah like
if I get it one hour before the audition
I don't read it cuz then each is gonna
throw me
I'm gonna read it so fast I'm not gonna
understand so I go to the audition and I
break down the actual audition you know
so bro it's crazy because you know like
writers leave clues of what they really
want man
so like I have to it's a fun gay man
like you and baguette like top words you
know like like words that are there for
a reason or words that repeat yeah
everything like that just for a for
example for example what
no no what you're gonna skip some
example of the clues in a writer leaves
you know like for me in deadly class
that there was like I remember the
actual world because I addition for
venom bro you did yeah addition for that
part a middle middle river I got the
security guard welcome to the building
homes but I'm gonna be in the Benham -
i'ma play carne carnage carnage asada
I hope our car needs a satyr oh I love
Woody Harrelson man I respect him a lot
but uh but you didn't like that I didn't
in the book but the cast no no no I like
him and I like him but the the casting
for Cletus or I don't know what his name
is the real carnage yeah - I'm already I
know it threw me off man no no for
because my CD test supposed to be young
like 20 yeah like 27 with like a big
afro and he and his skinny ass hell
maybe like the kid who was in Batman
like the the little kid Batman the
redheaded one that was playing the Joker
that good cleaning Peter Parker is
spider-man yeah Cletus Kasady is carnage
carnage he was in the prison when Tom
Hardy yeah and some of that's a lousy
riding man come on but when I get out of
here I'm bringing carnage like so you
get the audition right you nailed it
right and they kill you for a callback
to come back off book do you come train
with the character Chris Merrett
audition man tomorrow for a flight
attendant
and you know these Python shoulder
bralette evoke an airbag Oh bro bro bro
that that is so risky man it'll pay off
sometimes but like I've had people get
mad at me because I come in in costume
they're like no man an addition for
Lucifer Lucifer for the devil you know
in a you know in a red suit really
really close to what what I word you
know like a red flag like shiny suit red
all over and I went in the audition and
the girl just look at me and say bro
please take it take it off much I'm like
okay what a [ __ ] man no I think she's
trying to help him she's disgusting I
have just like the shirt I still do it I
did she probably wanted a pothead okay
and everybody that was a pothead and and
then when I was leaving this guy's came
in there laughing I already character he
he gave me a high five and it was that
asian guy from sixteen Candles and I
feel had a [ __ ] wig bro he put in a
[ __ ] weird like a STONER bro
anywhere a Corolla t-shirt you know but
then Rick's right Reese pay off because
you know my audition for deadly class
the audition for my character Chico it
involved a fight in the audition it's
just like Mark you saw somebody Marcus
elbow Chico in the face
Chico gets up and nice Marcus in the
face and puts our knife to his throat I
was like yo how am I gonna do this by
myself
we're not like same Lopez this weekend
and so a buddy of mine he's a
cinematographer and I told him like hey
man I need I need help with an audition
and he's like yeah
sure what you need I'm like I'm gonna
choreograph a fight and we're gonna send
it and see how it works and so we went
to a back yard instead of you know like
the white wall yeah and I got a friend
of mine come over and we choreographed
the other fight the guy just pulled out
the phone and he was like wow can I send
the text I'm gonna kill you right here
cuz that boom shoot and we sent it and
it worked and you got it they were like
we we want to meet him we want to we
want him to send the audition again like
he should have you know in front of our
white wall
no one involved talking to someone
behind camera but we loved what he did
and I was like did day and it was a risk
that paid off man because you know the
crazy thing is I was still filming with
Telemundo and they're like eh you're
gonna come to Vancouver to do the camera
tests to the chemistry reads and I was
like I can't guys I'm in Mexico I'm
filming a show right now I'm about to
finish and then I'll be there they're
like we need you for the camera test
they said listen we want to get pesos or
dollars yeah exactly
literally and the thing is and the thing
is I I had a contract man and I was like
ah guys I can't I can't fly what what do
we do and they're like okay give us a
few thing a few days to think about it
so that's really gonna play there just a
smaller story no way so just the
jessep's malli story bro you gonna play
him who's that Empire oh I'm gonna play
him in a movie no I follow the first
season of Empire about Jesse no I just
know lucious and cook that's okay this
guy he reported that two guys jumped out
one is this one way so is this all part
of the show Empire no no the actor the
actor actor yeah yeah they're about to
write him out of the show so he I'm not
saying allegedly but I'm gonna say you
say about what they said they got
attacked he filed a report then they
showed the - dude that allegedly
attacked him though he said I was
attacked by two men
warriors guys
attacked by tumeric America great guys
and they put it if they put a loose on
me to hang me and they were saying the
actor said make actor yeah Wow later it
turns out at the newest evidence
those two guys said that he paid them
and they choreographed a fight and
everything and so now he's lawyering up
he's got a criminal lawyer he he just
hired and like a fixer like somebody to
fix this PR she gets the same publicity
they run of easy guys why would he do
that
I don't know that's what I really mean
that's what Philippe us the other day
he's like what's wrong with him do that
really one of their national class that
there was a threat of a threatening
letter a few days before the attack and
I guess it didn't get enough attention
and he was upset that this wasn't a
bigger story Bunny's like all those
politicians that we're all like saying
this is a new that you want to believe a
victim when they're saying something
like this but these are believers they
want just like this is like they might
as well have drawn snidely whiplash
moustaches on the people you know like
hey it was a coldest weekend of Chicago
who hangs out over there the worst
megawhatts in Chicago the thing that got
to me was getting beat up and then them
yelling this is Magga country that's
just so much my kago that's like I said
I was writing me
that smacks of an actor see what happens
that dude if he's gonna go to jail
I couldn't he can and now back to the
show who does he play on Empire Jamal
he's the mean I would have thought it
was the other one but crazy no I'm just
gonna say more to the not believing this
story it's just that it's ten degree
weather and like they are out
specifically to find him and there
waiting for him yeah you were little
fool but you were enough you know I was
running from the cops and I found a
ditch and then I got hurt I [ __ ] up my
leg and I told my friend got jumped by
races neo-nazis right now way to project
regulating no I fell a Nazi skinheads
wearing Doc Martin in white laces so
what so food came by last year's huh
what's up hey no UFC party Kimball asked
is there now came to Lawson yeah I
forgot for who the brother was but he
got knocked out in like 47 seconds 26 no
wait who this weekend it was a first
fighter you have on ESPN Wow perfect the
bite he talked about perfectly just was
just enough time for the next shot to
started and that's crazy you know cuz
like they have to time it like all right
that's that's how you know like some of
the fights are not no contact like they
can last a minute they can last 12
rounds or UFC three was so full Johnny
Rocco had wearing what you worry bro I
let him in jacket from high school
wrestling
give me a Jew I played sports in high
school well you got that nah man it was
always my dream to have like a jacket
like that you know by the Bell
I always wanted to go to prom I was one
of our city jacket and [ __ ] I already
did with with my show sci-fi in deadly
class we have like a deadly prom and so
yeah we got in a huge fight between the
characters it was it was amazing but I
did play a soccer would you make that
bro you'll be like the little bit
general that one right there 5k runner
II imagine and so I played a lot of
soccer man you know when I was a kid I
was I was a goalkeeper he grew up
playing with a bunch of rich kids no not
at all you know I need real quick but
when I was we talked about it in our
podcast many many months so the speed of
Wayne hell yeah my brother angel Esparza
who the ginger right now probably
listening through satellite he we had we
had a foreign exchange student from
Mexico City
yeah they would Javier okay you know
Richie was broke he too played Pop
Warner football like tackle football
what an order we like real football like
American football in Mexico City no you
could bring heavy air bro I'll travel
dude so my brother went to live with him
in Mexico City and he took him to
Chiapas they took him to the pyramids
yeah I was there recently you come into
my house when you were a bro to live
with me yeah that's how it was for that
kid Wow can you imagine being a foreign
exchange student and ending up in the
projects in East LA as your
please well imagine yourself in the
worst role in east los I know things
like in my school in elementary we did
our within a foreign student thing and
we had five students from Australia to
come to Mexico City to and they were so
rigid shitless they were there were
fearing for her life happier every day
DNA soon can go away our house we had a
two bunk beds and in a bit 1 bit but
there were three people so he had to go
in a bunk and a top one and like
something I will get mad bro and I would
take the latter away
are you gonna get up there brother you
can't get on my bed for those 30 days of
those 15 days about one ice cube row in
the car I just made my bed and so we
went to swim yeah yeah
but it would through South bro if we if
we make this in the next few years
because that's how I pictured him
looking yo I go to the beach for three
days and I'll come back tomorrow at the
time Bobby Lee's girlfriend some people
burn you burn you didn't like [ __ ]
James Brown dark I don't know about
James Brown drunk but definitely darker
I got red paper I got sand paper I got
like a nice yeah you look like your
picture with your little suit on all
brown
haven't been out in the Sun one of the
immigration attorneys bro I was actually
gonna be a soccer player you know like I
was gonna be signed by Cruz Azul which
is a baby brother my cousin paper crew
has to employ a goalie nice you will be
played by
yeah Conejo yeah yo el Conejo Paris
Oscar he's a recent so yeah I was gonna
be a goalie for Cruz Azul but you know
in Mexico like soccer is like a really
serious business and so what they would
do is like okay we're gonna bring you to
a concentration camp and you're gonna
leave in the concentration camp Monday
through Saturday and only Sundays you
can see your family and my mom's like a
head now [ __ ] you guys I'm like nah mom
he's my dreams he's like no way I'm not
leaving you man sorry I'm like eating my
dream up and so good for her man I need
the right move and I was gonna be
leaving like two hours away and I was 12
you know so so station soon yeah so she
did out she did a good job man and I
didn't wanna be an actor cuz I was like
when I was really young I would live in
the shadow of my mom you know like I
would be like oh [ __ ] I'm the son of
Consuela
I'm never gonna be more than that you
know you're the son of consume like no I
am the son of concern I'm really proud
to be but I'm my own person
I'm age 12 and so when I when I decided
I wanted to go into acting I was like
I'm gonna go everywhere that my mom
didn't go you know so I went out of
Televisa when also at the Telemundo I
went out of Mexico went to Los Angeles
and I'm really proud to like open my own
doors because you know people would be
like oh you got that because you're the
son of cops hell yeah oh no use all bad
if you're playing
because you're the son of Consuela ah he
probably got it because he's the son of
Consuela and I'm like okay i'ma prove
you wrong so I went to different
stations where Consuelo is nothing you
know and I got my own chances I got my
own doors opened in Mexico popper thing
though because you remember that I told
you that that guy's advice for Josh
Duhamel Josh Duhamel was on that show
Vegas he started on All My Children
and he told him don't stay longer there
like three years at this job because
then you'll just be a soap opera yeah
that's how everybody will see you and
and so he left soon after Luke is a
lifer yeah he's a lifer all those people
patch was a life you know patch was on
the show with that patches you will have
a show days of our lives yeah but one of
the guys on the show
Donovan he ended up being the husband
and the nanny oh yeah was bad apple you
know that the nanny
yeah but the dude the British guy in a
Days of Our Lives I know the HEPA
telenovela la right he disappears and
then his twin brother shows up you
survived the plane crash with the
villain yo brother the villain back and
and I was gonna say the twin brother
Pico
crazy story man there was a there was a
story in Telemundo we're in this
telenovela this guy is playing boy twin
brothers you know the bad and the good
and I don't remember his name
maybe not even a lot of say it but like
the good guy would be this and the bad
guy would be the thing is getting so
much into the character that he started
referring himself as a third person so
he would go on to set and he'd be like
hey guys Michelle wants to go to the
bathroom and so you'd be like okay you
can go right now I can meet she'll come
in and you're like yeah come on come in
man and so I feel like he he had a crush
on an actress and then pop to her house
out of nowhere he's like come in and the
[Applause]
actual work everyday the same so when
you're to load the novella I know that
that in America also like when you get
there the script always changes but at
least they have the courtesy to send
your mail changes on the script you can
find them on read so you like go through
the script and you find read because it
never happened to you the row of each
other will be played by a really good
throw yesterday you know like something
you did your role or something
yeah the unification there's one up in a
row no but I've heard stories of like
our actors that become way too like pain
in the ass and suddenly the the
characters like okay Felipe I'll be
right back and he goes to the room and
when he comes back he's another actor
it's like hey Felipe so what are we
gonna do another actor of Campinas is
Right punch hammer
I report you about the other day but
literally and it happens man and like
they rehire people in the middle of
production or instead of just making
this appear man or like the bad the
villain well got a bomb in her face and
she had a facial surgery and it's now
another actress well yeah I think be
holy actually you tore up man inside the
green room how many chicks no not a lot
man that [ __ ] waiting for you like [ __ ]
died Harvey Weinstein with a script I
would be I would be waiting in the RV
[Laughter]
likes to go I think of Robert Rob
Schneider was on Howard Stern he goes
out what's the craziest thing you ever
saw Stephens to go above the law
students to go call me over to his
dressing room and he answered is that
the room in his kimono bro no wonder
where nothing on and he was I just read
the most amazing script I ever read in
my [ __ ] life
Rob Schneider who wrote it but that fool
got busted was a medley [ __ ] everyone
they don't like so crazy man I think
women years later go in to have sex and
then yank the wig off on top people to
take a quick little selfie yeah oh yeah
you got the man but it's crazy cuz it
also affects the whole environment you
know like in Summit and soul when
someone shows that I was filming like
people go black
hey no more than 10 seconds because then
it's a sexual harassment and it's like a
joke but it's like like you you feel
that there's attention all right okay
guys we're gonna start filming
remember tips of the day don't get close
to and it's like really matter like are
we talking about this right now and so
it's it's crazy man
it's response with your head a little
bit when you're at the big boss man and
it only the thing is what if you're
acting you're acting man but like like
at least for me like a Mexican Latino
like I go up to people like hey how you
doing and I go for a kiss every time
that I say hello and some some girls are
like it's like oh [ __ ] you get annoyed
you get paranoid you're like really [ __ ]
up and it's like nah man like it's all
about chill but it is that touchy feely
anyway the reason I got into it because
I want to rub shoulders for the shoulder
road let's say in the theater it's like
that yo of a theater is another world
man like theater is like like you you
get naked in front of the whole cast
mates while you're changing and nobody
gives a [ __ ] girl guy does not matter
but you know in Mexico there was a
really young show like a TV like high
school type of show everyone was like 15
to like 18 and that show turned into
like a orgy and to prepare the panel's
literally man it's crazy because I I'm
coming home and the thing is like okay
they did the earth like the thing and
then in Mexico there was a they try to
do a me-too movement the thing is like
the actress and really spoke up got
rejected by everyone at Prairie I think
it's harder out there to do it out that
he was like I'm sure like maybe like two
or three years ago they try to do like a
Harvey Weinstein type of thing in Mexico
and the thing is like they dated a year
before and so like the story was there's
no one why's that it didn't make sense
any backfired on her a lot and so I'm
just thinking like if that me to thing
goes into Mexico like those guys in the
show like they could they can talk about
like some serious [ __ ] that went on set
so it's it's crazy man like at the end
of the day it's a job I know especially
with all those [ __ ] that'll goes
around and Televisa and all that scary
place which over here to squish over
here snoring where can people find you
we're down Michelle guys remember you
can find me at Instagram Mitch
underscore Deauville mich note e mich
underscore duv al you can find me on
instagram i have a little production
house in mexico city so you can find me
on youtube as luna films I have like
original content I'm partnered up with
our business friend of mine so we throw
sketches webseries I'm on Twitter to you
you'll find me same same handle yeah so
you'll find me
best toggle you ever had it Mexico City
where at wow they're not considered
tacos but they're called Co stress which
is like a taco cost resolved and a
shudder called man it's just
unbelievable Costra is a taco but with
like a layer of cheese made Lolita like
hard well that's basically like your
tostada the cheese oh yeah yeah I've
seen those yeah that's more about cam
okay you know it's crazy because I can
is it's the same thing as yeah yeah kind
of you know a Costra
is a bull can just folded up and the
fact that you folded up the tortilla
makes it a coaster
notable cam the mall is open like I've
seen it's like that you don't of meat
then you close it yeah and normally that
she goes dry because he has a layer of
burnt cheese inside yeah so that's what
makes it a couple people meanwhile
Kamali
everything else right yo I'm a disgrace
to my country because I do not [ __ ] with
avocado and beans I don't need what come
only I don't need a Vaquero but I go you
know like that gusto that goes up a
story's my my everything it was a little
bit of pineapple pineapple pineapple the
way man with everything
[Music]
oh I'm at the dojo tonight and then I
have a show at the Harvard Yard bar in
Koreatown on Thursdays oh wow
Raleigh North Carolina yo will be a
Raleigh North Carolina did you impress
the gentleman don't free get about these
days I heard some some slang or Everett
my friend her boyfriend is from Mexico
City and this has some crazy slang that
I've never heard before know some
chilaquiles mean no but he has a son and
she laughs no no son she's not about
food at all it's not easy it's not fast
she Longo don't eat beans yeah and then
there's another one she said she said
there's so many defects for example
someone asks they can they say esta casa
you can answer so Sarita yeah so she
thought which means like yours truly is
truly it's like serving the world
and instead of saying yeah one so put up
again man February 22nd to 24th this
week this week I mean Raleigh North
Carolina with Tobey Higgs if you want to
get hit me up ed fans at Philippa's
WorldCom ask for them if you want to get
for Miami hit me up at fans affiliated
WorldCom March a to attend brand new
improv hit me up San Angelo Texas March
15 which atok has days March 16 Grand
Junction Colorado March 23rd Dallas
Texas March 29
throughout 31st also people I'm coming
to New York City Caroline's in June 22 a
22nd also I'm coming to hopefully I'm
coming to the San Jose improv we're
gonna do it live I might have murder
thank you thank you they